CBS News travel editor Peter Greenberg
joins us at the table with the latest on
this Peter everybody wants to know how
long will they take to get back to
normal because it seems that just
because the planes are flying doesn't
mean the passengers are that's right
it's a two-part answer it'll probably
take Delta another 24 hours to get back
to speed operationally remember they
cancelled 900 flight yesterday another
400 today actually 300 Delta another
hunter from the other airlines but they
gotta get the planes back to Atlanta so
they can operate those they will do that
but the crews are out of sequence the
planes are out of cycle so that's part A
Part B is what's gonna happen to the
passengers that's right the planes are
already full throughout the rest of this
week so if you're holding a reservation
for the 17th which was you know
yesterday that doesn't mean you're
getting out today or tomorrow because
those are reservations for those flights
today are already going to be honors
either how significantly does this
ripple out through other airports big
time because remember Atlanta may be the
busiest airport but not because people
fly to it they fly through it so it's
all about connectivity so you have
people throughout the country who can't
get back to where they wanted to go
through Atlanta which means plan B for
them is how are they going to get there
without going through Atlanta so the
Atlanta mayor said that the backup power
system also went down you need a
dedicated power system and a backup
power system for the airport itself not
substations a long line because when
that happened it tripped and tripped and
tripped and it couldn't handle it
remember when you close the airport
you're doing a ground stop that means
nothing moves that's why those
passengers were trapped on the planes
that did get into Atlanta because they
couldn't operate the jet ways they could
not break the escalators and let's not
even talk about where the baggage went
yeah and what about direct flights they
also take a big hit here too well they
do we're talking about the international
flights right they had to be diverted
and once you divert an international
flight you better hope it's going to a
place that has a US Customs facility
they're low on fuel and they can't get
their passengers back until they get
them back through Atlanta because that's
their contract of carriage so those
international flights you got people
overseas who can't get out because those
planes haven't come back so Peter I got
I've got a daughter coming home from
college a lot of people are traveling
for the holidays and they're sitting at
home going is this going to affect me
well it is but the way you're gonna have
to look at is this you've got to come up
with a contrarian view travel here
non-stop flights forget them they're
already full so if you're going from
Atlanta to Los Angeles welcome to st.
Louis
welcome to
welcome to Chicago and welcome to Salt
Lake City because you're not going to
get there non-stop those planes are
absolutely full now what the airlines
are doing they're offering waivers all
the airlines are doing about saying if
you were going to or through Atlanta
you can rebook or cancel and refund with
no penalty or change fees that's the
good news the bad news is rebooking
ain't gonna be easy
Wow Peter Greenberg you've always got
the best information works thank you
thank you